internet et la loire de gérants de
serveurs sur le web comme on dit
viennent d'être mis en examen pour
diffusion d'image pédophiles la loi qui
réprime cela existe mais comment la
faire appliquer alors que l'accès à
internet est libre il suffit de payer un
abonnement un centre serveur qui ne peut
pas vu le nombre de connexions contrôler
le contenu des documents échangés
une mise en examen qui a donc fait
réagir les professionnels christine le
héros didier bonnet tempête dans
l'univers d'internet en guise de
protestation
les professionnels ont bouclé l'accès
aux newsgroups ces forums de libre
écriture que l'on peut consulter sur le
réseau les professionnels collecte et
transporte en fait les informations que
l'on peut ensuite consulter sur son
ordinateur
certaines se sont révélés horna lourd il
peut se glisser dans certains newsgroups
dont le libellé n'est pas évident si
vous avez un news où il s'appelle
erotica bon il n'ya pas de quoi fouetter
un chat après oui maintenant il peut se
glisser dans ce newsgroups des photos
contraires à la loi type et de clips
mais ça on ne peut pas nous contre les
deux cent mille messages par jour
c'est comme si on demandait à un
marchand de journaux de contrôler tous
les magazines qu'il reçoit tous les
matins pour être sûr que page
164 il ya pas une petite annonce
pédophiles ou une photo d'un adolescent
n'ont pas de statut pas de règles
clairement définis la déferlante
internet est allé plus vite que la
législation en accepterait de supprimer
des informations à condition qu'ils ne
soient indiquer exactement ce qu'on doit
supprimer et à condition aussi que nous
indique le moyen technique pour le faire
il ya certaines choses qui sont faisable
envisageable mais par exemple de dire
qu'on va supprimer tout contenu
pornographique des news par exemple si
on nous le demandait on ne sait pas
faire et je ne crois pas qu'il existe
aujourd'hui un moyen technique pour le
faire parce que ça menacerait le net en
france si on me demandait réellement
d'eux
surveiller tous les contenus pour met à
disposition nos utilisateurs on sera
obligé de fermer boutique vérifier par
soi même
les milliers de messages rapatriés du
monde entier chaque jour la tâche est
titanesque
les professionnels estiment en tout cas
un possible humainement à l'échelle de
leur entreprise